today we're talking about pub sub and
bigquery cloud analytics and the data
engineering spotlight
i'm piccola and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
you no longer have to write or run your
own pipelines for data ingestions from
pub sub into bigquery
we are introducing a new type of pub sub
subscription called a bigquery
subscription that writes directly from
cloudpop sub to bigquery
this new extract load and transform elt
path will be able to simplify your
event-driven architecture
learn more about how to get started on
the blog
today's security data is heterogeneous
including logs and alerts and often
comes from more than one cloud platform
in order to better analyze the data
we're excited to announce the release of
the cloud analytics project by the minor
ingenuity center for threat informed
defense and sponsored by google cloud
and several other industry collaborators
since 2021 google cloud has partnered
with the center to help level the
playing field for everyone in the cyber
security community by developing open
source security analytics
head to the blog for more in the past
decade we have experienced an
unprecedented growth in the volume of
data that can be captured recorded and
stored
in addition the data comes in all shapes
and forms speeds and sources
this makes data accessibility data
accuracy data compatibility and data
quality more complex than ever before
which is why this year at our data
engineer spotlight we wanted to bring
together the data engineering community
to share important learning sessions and
the newest innovation in google cloud
check out the on-demand session
workshops and our top five takeaways on
the blog
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you